cloud bigtable is google cloud's nosql
database that's optimized for use cases
with high numbers of reads and writes
per second at low latency
in previous episodes we learned about
bigtable's speed scale and reliability
as well as how it's being used for use
cases like personalization and fraud
detection
in this episode we're going to learn
more about how bigtable can be used in
the adtech industry
[Music]
have you ever browsed one of your
favorite websites and seen an
advertisement that just happens to align
with your interests the advertising
technology or ad tech industry is all
about the systems software and tools
that advertisers use to deliver digital
ads to potential customers the goal of
ad tech is to help both publishers and
advertisers optimize their online ad
campaigns
publishers which could include popular
websites and mobile apps want to
monetize their digital space by serving
ads to their users
advertisers on the other hand want to
optimize the roi of ad campaigns for
their products by efficiently reaching
target customers
one of the most popular ad tech models
is the open exchange where automated
real-time bidding options are used to
decide which ad appears in front of a
user as they load a page
another important part of ad tech is
using the power of data to help digital
advertisers reach the right audiences
some examples of data that might be
helpful include demographics referring
sites
search queries
behavior on the site and interaction
with ad content when you go on a
publisher app or website the publisher
might send information to an ad exchange
that will look you up by identification
or by cohort and characteristics
different ad tech companies might offer
different solutions but the pattern of
looking up the user is similar
sounds like a good case for a key value
store no
bigtable is a great database solution
for ad tech companies because of several
key business critical challenges they
face
first had tech companies need to make
sure that they can serve ads as fast as
possible when a user opens a page
delivering ads faster translates to a
better user experience making potential
customers more likely to click on ads
and improve roi for advertisers
in practice this means that many ad tech
companies need database requests to have
latency on the order of single digit
milliseconds
bigtable is a great option for this use
case since it's designed to support
large numbers of reads and writes per
second at low latency
tech companies also need a database that
can scale
they might have billions of ad requests
per day and millions of requests per
second
this kind of extremely high throughput
might overwhelm many on-premise or
traditional databases luckily bigtable
is designed for this exact use case it
supports up to millions of read and
write requests per second and can store
up to petabytes of data
throughput can be adjusted dynamically
by adding or removing bigtable nodes
each of which provides up to 10 000
digital queries per second as well as
additional storage capacity ad tech
companies also want to focus on their
core technology like the machine
learning algorithms used to optimize ad
placement rather than worry about how to
manage their underlying database
infrastructure
as a fully managed database service
bigtable makes it easy for development
teams to focus on innovation rather than
reinventing the wheel
bigtable replicates data across multiple
google data centers all around the world
to maintain high availability and low
latency for users everywhere
this makes it easy for ad tech companies
to seamlessly expand to new markets
without having to worry about managing
the data centers themselves
bigtable also handles backups so ad tech
companies can easily recover from
application level data corruption as
well as human error
ad tech companies also find bigtable
useful because of how easy it is to
integrate with other google cloud
products
some companies have used memory store
from memcached to cache frequently query
data
this can help get latency down to lower
than one millisecond and also help
optimize bigtable costs
other companies have also extensively
used bigquery google cloud's large-scale
data warehouse for storage and analysis
while bigtable can handle very high
throughput at low latency
bigquery can be better for large scale
data analysis
in the ad tech space bigquery can be
helpful for data scientists who may want
to compile analytics and dashboards to
help advertisers and publishers meet
their goals
powerful and complex queries that may
take several minutes to complete with
other databases may take just seconds
with bigquery
and finally
tech companies rely heavily on machine
learning to take the data that's
available and use it to better connect
advertisers and potential customers
vertex ai is google cloud's unified
machine learning platform that makes it
easy for businesses to build deploy and
scale ml models on google's
infrastructure
as you can see bigtable's speed
scalability and reliability make it a
great fit for the unique challenges of
ad tech
if you're curious to learn more take a
look at the links below
thanks for joining us today and take a
look at the other episodes in the series
to learn more about bigtable